explosive content
jeff bezos and amazon now own all
the apprentice outtakes and one trump
may or may not have said page three oh
my gosh
here we go again this is this is epic
here and who out of everybody would buy
this okay
so explosive content jeff pesos and
amazon now own
all the apprentice outtakes and what
trump may or may not have said this a vt
post story by tom center jeff bezos
maybe speak is seeking to release
outtakes from the apprentice that show
its host
former president donald trump making
racist and sexist comments although the
pro-trump and anti-trump
factions aren't likely to change their
stance the amazon purchase mgm catalog
including the princeton's
apprentice is steering the conversation
stephen colbert
eagerly introduced the idea during the
late show last week why would one of the
world's richest man pay
almost twice the value for a struggling
movie studio and
that recently went bankrupt well it
could be that jeff pesos has an
ongoing feud with the former president
genghis khan he calls trump genghis khan
guess what all the outtakes from the
apprentice are owned by mgm
holy mother of dvd extras the private
footage of a tv billionaire is going to
belong to an
actual billionaire holy meaning trump's
not
a god billionaire wow actor tom arnold
fueled the fire in 2018 saying i've seen
a compilation tape that my buddy shared
with me he said the n-word he says
he called eric the r word and uh it's
not looking good so what are your
thoughts since you wrote the story
it comes down to this how petty is jeff
bezos i mean does he have bigger things
to worry about than this
or would he actually do something now
there there's some
there's some substance to this as far as
what corbeau says because
here's what what did they get for this
purchase he they definitely may have
overpaid for this thing you get the
james bond franchise
which is you know i don't know how big
that is in the long run you get the
rocky franchise
tomb raider real housewives fargo
handmaid's tale jack ryan but did he do
this just to get those outtakes now
number one would anyone even be
surprised i mean if trump said this
don't we kind of expect this i mean he
survived what he said on axis hollywood
with billy bush
two weeks before the election so i don't
think it would matter one way or another
it would give the the left a little
chuckle you know and they would enjoy
seeing this
um but again it just comes down to how
petty he is and
whether he wants to do this and who's in
his ear because
i think bezos doesn't give a crap about
this one way or another i don't i don't
think you can be as successful as jeff
bezos and make emotional decisions that
are stupid
so who's in his ear somebody that has
influence somebody that really wants
them to do it we'll see
and then it comes down to do they even
have the contractual or licensing
agreement to air some of this because
mark burnett
tried to tie a lot of this stuff up so
it couldn't get out there
let me just say this if there's any of
this stuff that exists of trump saying
the n word or the art what's the r word
[ __ ]
i think so talking about his son that
would be my guess the r word
because they said talk about eric with
the r word disrespectful for your son
that's unbelievable
yeah um the r word yeah i guess never
never go
full r word never do that um but if that
stuff
existed it'd be out there already i
don't give a [ __ ] if bezos bought this
mgm owned this if trump if there was
actual footage of trump doing this kind
of stuff as our good friend tom arnold
um alludes to it'd be out there already
are you kidding me you think they're
gonna keep that
buried for five years not a chance and
here's the biggest point here
it says although the pro-trump or the
anti-trump factions
aren't likely to change their stances
the amazon purchased
might start the conversation hell no it
ain't starting the conversation
if there's one thing that trump did is
he drew a line in the sand and said you
were
with me or against me and everyone fell
in line how many people are
lukewarm on trump at this point well you
know i'm i might or might not be in on
trump like
he made it very clear that he's like i'm
here you're either with me or you're
against me and america fell online
so again if this stuff's out there it
exists and
to me it does it's he's probably never
said that because we've seen that
already here's here's how
all i know every everything i see here
with all the moves that are being
made on the left or people of power like
bezos like zuck
like dorsey likes like everybody
on the left that's making these
decisions it just tells me one thing
trump's running 2024.
there's no question about it he's
running there's no question about it
trump's going to run next two years why
why do you care
why do you care they're preparing that
in case he runs
this stuff's not going to come out next
year you know when that stuff's going to
come out about
apprentice exactly in 24 months not
today it's going to come out in 24
months and in 24 months we're all going
to be sitting there saying
what is that all about and people going
to say wait a minute i think everywhere
yeah so everything that's going on with
this
everything that's going on with this is
one thing why are people paying twice
the amount of money for
mgm it's only one reason there's only
one reason why somebody would do this
because everybody believes
trump's going to run in two years that's
their biggest fear they cannot handle
another four years of trump of calling
them
out every single day look how peaceful
it is right now they can do their side
deals they can do their negotiation they
don't want another trump to be up there
they're so frightened none of this stuff
is going to show up for at least
24 months i see within 24 months all the
stuff that they have on the apprentice
is going to show up and i wouldn't be
surprised if that's that's why i
wouldn't be out there already
no no why why would you show it right
now why wouldn't you show it
when j edgar hoover when the mob had
stuff on j
edgar hoover they went up to him and
they just showed it to them they said
look we know who you are
look at these pictures cross-dressing if
you do anything and you say there is
such a thing as a mob we just want to
let you know we're going to show this to
the world
and they never don't care i don't think
trump cares uh i i think if they have
this
explosive content yeah that would not
stop him from running i don't think it
would stop him from running i'm just
telling you this stuff that they're
getting i don't know if it's gonna stop
them from running
i just think stuff that they're gonna
use to you know you're a professional
forecaster and you've never been wrong
what are the odds trump runs against
this for effect i honestly don't think
trump's going to run again really i
really don't
and i think this will be the least of
his worries because he can handle this i
think it's the the indictments that's
coming out of new york i think it's the
legal battles that he's going to be
facing the next couple years
i think at some point he loses interest
i really do i mean he's going to be 75
years old if he's not already
i still don't think he's going to run i
think i disagree well you know that's
fine but i think there's going to be
other viable candidates on the
republican side
and the power of the republican is going
to try to get desantis or
wherever the momentum is so i you're
asking my opinion i'm just saying i
don't think trump will run
do you think he's going to run or no oh
there's no there's no question about it
no questions so if you're watching this
guy's got nothing else going on if
you're watching this thumbs up he's
running thumbs down he's not running
thumbs up he's running thumbs on he's
not running 421 90
i'm just curious to know what people are
going to say thumbs up he's running
sometimes he's not running i'm looking
at it here
on what the okay 421
20. we're going to get 90
that he's running all right i guarantee
you we'll see what happened here with
that
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you